i can't really be a lawyer  and a criminal can i i want to win  but do i want to win like this i'm of  two minds here  so it's a coin flip  johnny vedi was murdered tonight falcone  crime family has to be taken down  there's only room for one homicidal  maniac in this town  why are you running you could use a  little fun  i thought you didn't hurt people  you thought wrong  you still haven't figured out who killed  johnny viti  a killer who only works on holidays  there's lots of crazy out there  once i take him out things are gonna be  different we can start a family  the city has fallen alfred and we must  endeavor to lift it up again  [Music]  who is holiday and who's next  you